こんにちはー
こんにちは
次は部なんかないんだけどね変だ挨拶やなかなか新しい挨拶など考えてください
ちょっとコメント欄で新しい者考えてください僕も今度からちょっと新しいあいさつで
行くんで同容疑でこんちゃー肇社長です皆さんは大数といいぐ3
知ってますかオストリーグ制というのがあるんですけどもまぁこちらがオスですねまぁ
一般患者の馬場
一般家庭のお姉さん方は
ぶつかってる道すらない薬でセルベールドがストールっていう
トレードに一緒に買ってきたんですけどもうちょっとね
超あるちょっとねとある情報によるとはオス取り稼ぎが混ぜると爆発するっていう話を
ききました
んちょっと怪しいなちょっとところですね相当怪しいけどもうちょっとような怪しいと
思ったしないと思いましたけど意外と年ありかもしれないってちょっと僕の考えです
意外とアリかもしれないですなぜかというとですねそもそも胃薬てどこに入ると思い
ますか
そう言いだよな即刻体の中の位に入るわけなんだけども
胃の中には何があるでしょそう
持参で水産三田でさ賛成であのほぼの音加瀬さんがあるわけなんですよでなっても描く
がストールってことはないが頭をコーナー化するんですよガスを南下するその山の中に
これを入れてガス代コーナーがするんですよ多分
で探すでしょで山の中に入れてこれがガスが反応するでこれもねあのを吸ってるみんな
知らないと思うんですけど多分賛成なんです
これを三男でショットしてこれが nathan とでちょっと倉庫関係があって
oem 風呂でのこの爆発的反応をショットするとその if せると押すだけで
出来るかもしれないという僕の考えです
俺もちょっとよくわかんないんだけどもバンチャンあるでこれワンチャンある
ひょっとしたらダイバーがするんですよね
さっそくやってみましょう爆発パターン
基本信じてないんですけどもう本当になぜかどうかわかんないすべきでありますからね
粒タイプとこのタイプの二種類があるんですけどまずはまあがストール怪しいの
ちょっと傘発生するのでガストアートでしまうと先にこのセルベールからいきますで
待つなく小分けだってき強くなってきちゃった
怖い
で大丈夫で生まれとビビってるよなまずは胃薬を入れましょう
爆発したら動画的には嬉しいよ動画的には嬉しいけどいつ個人的にはすごい嫌ですよ市
湖南入れました
待って怖いよ本当に怖いよをキャスト入れましょう
これを入れて爆発したら動画的においしい顔らしい
我と割と強いからねぜひ2
ワンッ
あー ok ですこだわたぶん大丈夫ですよず内心ほっとした10分とガックリした
自分がいますでは次は音や次はがストールでありこれねわからないでもがせって書いて
あるから食べこっちのメインでしょうねちょっと先に州からいいよ
あなたは
次はお酢を入れましたではがストールで爆発するかどうかやってみましょう
次 q 2はんな
反応している反応している堪能している
堪能してるぞ強い反応してるけど反応してる反応している
めっちゃは出てる分かるかぬめっちゃ合わせてるんですよ餌爆発官は勝つであるこれ
爆発緩和
爆発感はないかもしれない
どうやらん
デマだったようですねそれでは皆さん次回の動画でお会いしましょう
b 2